hey guys it's Dennis the founder think
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the pilot premiere
episode of almost human much-anticipated
I even a lot of a lot of money behind
this yeah look great got JJ Abrams
produced j JH wyman writing and you and
Karl Urban yeah we all know from Star
Trek and judge dredd and well just dread
starring the lead roles a lot of money a
lot of marketing a lot of hype has gone
into this show what did you think it was
I thought it was solid you know it
wasn't um anything like blew me away
necessarily wasn't oh my gosh is awesome
but I mean it's it's solid it's a good
pilot you know not all pilots are great
sometimes shows take a little while to
get into it but immediately right off
the bat I like the characters i like the
leads i like we'll see what the premise
to some of its still kind of miss you
gettin old in syndicate and all that but
I mean whatever mean I like the lead i
like i like these two guys I like Carlo
berman and Michael alia yeah his name
Dorian you know so I mean I'm invested
in the leads okay yeah I think that's
probably the strength of it so far is
that kind of Buchan chemistry between
carbon michael ealy is his John Andrew
and Dorian and look they're kind of like
the two wild cards right a little bit
yeah that's um loose wires you know yeah
there's no straight man they're both
know what the wild card uh yeah I
thought I thought I think solid is a
good word for ya it's not fantastic than
blowing mine and go oh my god you guys
have you know you have to see this but
it was good enough to keep on wall yeah
there for me to see where it goes right
the whole story line with the syndicate
yeah I don't know that that's one of
those things are good like a double
agree i'd be like cheesy or could be
good depends on how they're gonna thread
that through the whole series what I am
worried about is we get into a situation
that we have going on with agents of
shield right now in a lot of shows that
maybe later on turned out good like so
like friends
in the beginning where it's to episodic
where every episode at least in the
beginning is gonna be oh this is about
this one thing only right that's what
that's my concern I hope it doesn't
happen I think I don't know the full
counts I can don't quote me this but I'm
assuming this is not gonna be a full 20
episode season I don't know how you in a
bit more day yeah so that could help and
you know cuz long gonna be maybe like a
sleepy hollow wasn't gonna be 13
episodes and hopefully they'll get to
the you know the meat faster i hope so I
hope they don't drag specially with Karl
Urban I don't think he could even do
he's busy I don't think yeah you would
feel on thing you could do full 20
episodes so but you're right i hope it
gets going quick you know but right now
I mean I like I said I'm invested yeah
enjoy yeah you can definitely see the
production banjo plays it shot you know
with high-end camera there's a lot of
you know a lot costumes and cast even
pay homage to a little blade runner yeah
definitely had its like a blade runner
light right yeah it is heavy no no not
quite as dirty for his dingy it's kind
of like a kind of a cleaned-up Blade
Runner world you have instead of the
replicants you have the synthetics MX's
yeah it does seem like there's a scene
of the noodle house you know with all
the umbrellas in the rain I mean it
looked just like the scene that Harrison
Ford has and but I mean it was yeah I
know they did it on purpose of course it
was a good job yeah and I think one of
the themes hopefully in the show they'll
do the whole like what is is to be human
I'm it's called all humanity you know if
you any of you guys have seen
Spielberg's AI ya in which is also kind
of like a sci-fi version of Pinocchio
what does it run give you not a boy real
man but a real man this is like what
does it mean to be a real human right if
this guy can feel naw really see thinks
he can feel right and this I mean when
you get down to the meat of the show
this is still network it's still fox
that's the file I mean this is still a
cop procedural yes it's beautifully
masked you know looks great as you know
this futuristic science fiction so it's
all about in this town with a cop
procedure with nothing wrong with that i
mean i loved Hannibal as a cop
procedural too but it's like you have to
I hope it doesn't get too cliche with
anything you know go too on the nose
with some of the themes but
I don't think I mean I think with the
cast they have into the pilot an
indication think it's going to be a good
series oh I hope so yeah minka kelly in
there as long as she's gonna be the love
interest yeah right now and then the
twist of Carmen's characters
ex-girlfriend be a listener kitchen and
how that plays out so I you know I'm
very hopeful but at the same time I'm
still a little cautious nothing about
the pilot that made me cautious just in
general with these type of shows yeah I
mean I think I like a fox of all the
major networks NBC's starting to get
there a little bit but they I think they
take the most chances more than ABC
would more than you know CBS they
definitely try things other networks
would be afraid to so I'm glad to see
that we're having some hopefully some
good science fiction on televisions not
enough good science fiction out there
since Battlestar left need more science
fiction yeah also you know I am a bit
cautious just because i have seen pilots
in the past that I really liked and then
they kind of like flash forward you know
yeah I likewise with the first
Persepolis I was really good and then it
started you know going so that's why I'm
a little more cautious with something
like this sure definitely I mean some
shows don't start you well when they get
better so hopefully this one that stays
you know just kind of keeps literally
getting better and better i hope yeah
yeah i hope it gets maybe more serious
and right yeah gets into more longer
story arcs right right absolutely
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the pilot episode of almost human you
can post your comments below on the
website thing CARICOM or on our youtube
channel think hero pro make sure to
subscribe to that it will come chat with
us tonight on Twitter we're at think
here come talk to us you know about a
witch lot of the pilot it's the you know
second coming of the you know some great
new science fiction series personally
i'm at griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans make sure you like that
page and also you know share and tweet
or our videos and reviews on facebook or
twitter and all that stuff it really
helps us out
you